what are you noticing the AdSense uh on
the way their Platformers Rumble against
YouTube comparing the two I you know I
don't know because I haven't it would be
unfair for me to say because I've been
demonetized for so long on YouTube so I
don't really know what the industry is
like there yeah not only am I not
allowed uh to be monetized on YouTube
I'm not allowed to run ads through
AdSense so to give you other people can
run the exact yes the exact same ad like
if you can we've done a b testing on
this we've done a b testing yeah where
we try and run an ad like let's just say
it's a clip yeah right where you run as
a pre-roll or something say no
absolutely not and then we've had other
people with AdSense accounts who run it
and it gets accepted so it's not content
based it's us-based yeah Peak to Peak if
you were to say you know when I used to
get a million views I would make 7 800
on YouTube I'm just making some number
up when I get a million views on Rumble
I make XYZ have you put those two
together your numbers I'm assuming
you've done that to see how they match
up with advertising so that would be
more of a Gerald question again because
the rates change so dramatically that
YouTube at Peak was very different like
you I think I've been a partner since
2008 and I was very I wasn't even around
with the mcns like I don't remember like
makers and students of course uh so the
rates would change dramatically so it's
almost like you don't really have a
comparison I will say the numbers have
been I think actually better on a pound
for pound basis uh but we often don't
really seek to monetize the video no
because we we'd rather people feel like
they don't have to watch that and get
the show and subscribe so you don't even
monetize on Rumble right now you're not
turning it on I think it's on for some
of them but we don't spend it's such a
small business model right that's not
really how our model works we four went
a couple million dollars a year from
YouTube when we said okay keep it if you
want to demonetize this because it was
you know the carrot was dangled or just
don't talk about these things we said
nope keep us demonetized just don't
remove our Channel and we'll find a way
um naive question if you're not making
any money on YouTube and Rumble isn't a
money maker for you yeah is it all the
mug Club all the sponsors yeah okay
because there's so there's the
viewership is so large that one
sponsorship spot is worth you know four
or five
so uh people in the mud Club where are
they like on March 20th yeah correct
that uh you guys are coming back on
where where you guys are launching on
like on your website mainly this one
yeah it's not entirely finalized but
here's the thing we are launching
ladder's credit lottery.com who we're
still finalizing exactly who is going to
do the back end we're pretty close got
you uh but regardless people will be
able to go there Watch the free show
yeah like we always have and then
continue to watch the premium show and
the additional contest on the website
yeah right on the website 89 and uh for
the whole year yeah and actually and if
and if you are in myclub forever.com
where you subscribed you didn't we're
gonna send you a code where you actually
get a good few extra free months because
of the situation yeah because that's
something too again because it's like
nothing breaks my heart more than people
saying hey you know I didn't get a mug
or hey you know I subscribe at this
point in time when it's like you know at
some point right you end a contract at
some point you have to like but I hate
that you paid and you only got half a
year but since we can't access their
personal information like we can't know
so it's like you have to reach out to us
and we'll send you this code it'll
largely be honor System where we do
right by you and give you some extra you
know a few few months for free fantastic
yeah that's when I was wishing that I
hadn't taken the CEO job was when we
were getting to the end of the contract
and we had no idea who our subscribers
were
right and we've talked about this and it
was just like okay how do we go and
build this we have no way of getting in
touch with you guys we have yeah you
know like a master email list but that's
that's every single person who's ever
signed up for the newsletter through the
website or through what that number's
got to be in a million it's a lot of
people right but that's the thing it's
not specific and so if you send it a lot
of it maybe it goes to junk mail because
you're sending ads to them potentially
in in previous Partnerships it's like
man like that that's just a feeling of
like we've got to be able to capture
these people so that's where mud clubs
so oh so you brought I don't know if
that was going out the audience but yeah
that's the number of uh three months
pre-demonetization right 400
000. zoom in a little bit go ahead so
three months 430 000 was that uh average
from free demonetization and that's with
just the main channel that doesn't
include crowded bits about 60 about 62
million plays
um which is what we're getting an
average in a month between 50 and 70
million and of course that number went
down because you don't get browsers 50
to 70 million views per month yep okay
wow uh but an average of over a hundred
thousand new subscribers every month
every month and then if you go to uh
demonetization so even we were
demonetized all right we still had about
58 million so the numbers didn't quite
take uh because they took a while to get
us out of the browse and search uh
forty six thousand so almost to the
letter A tenth every single time they
remonetize us again accidentally someone
got fired wait wait wait this is in 90
days you got how many Subs 46 000.
versus 430 yep yeah that's great
immediately and then we have another did
your show stop did you change any of the
schedule no that's the thing nothing
basically they just turn you off or turn
you on turn you off and then we have
another one they're just doing after
that we're again remonetized right and
then this was oh so we remonetized for
two months
three months there so 213 and again it
took a little while to get but again 62
million plays and then demonetized again
and it went down to 23. and this is just
YouTube this is just you now so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]